merci à tous les cas d'être là on va
parler de mon inconnue c'est votre
nouveau long métrage hugo geslin qu'est
ce que vous avez ressenti tous les trois
à la lecture du scénario j'ai eu la
chance que moi
hugo mlle fasse lire en proposant
directement le rôle donc c'est vrai que
je le lisais à travers le prisme de ce
personnage et en projetant tout de suite
dans les scènes mais aussi je me suis
marré quoi je me souviens me vraiment me
taper des barres à voix haute chez moi
tout seul quoi donc ça c'est bon signe
généralement pour une comédie les
personnages je trouve son hyper
intéressant le personnage d'olivia du
coup que eu beau me faisais lire est
absolument génial parce qu'il ya donc
deux personnages en un ce qui est assez
rare et en plus de ça avec tout le piano
et où travailler piano à côté et pareil
puis l'envi de travailler avec hugo moi
je j'aime beaucoup son cinéma je me
souviens être allé voir comme des frères
tout seul au cinoche quand il était
sorti et et avoir tout de suite adoré
avec ce mélange qui l'a entre fait un
vrai cinéma d'émotion et en même temps
de divertissement et avec beaucoup
d'humour et beaucoup de sensibilité
beaucoup d'humanité et je crois que
l'envié du coût de 13 avec tué était
assez évident qu'à moi ça me paraissait
longue en lisant c'est aussi l'ambition
de cinéma de faire un film qui rassemble
plusieurs genres et l'excitation à la
lecture de me dire ça voilà c'est pas le
genre de choses qu'on lit beaucoup en
france ni convoi est peut-être plus ans
dans les pays anglo saxons angleterre
c'est vrai je n'ai jamais dit qu'on voit
jamais en france
et puis l'excitation de voir les
cabrioles des scénaristes est qui et qui
nous mène et qui nous est donc on tourne
les pages comme ça et voilà ça se
termine un peu tôt parce que c'était
bien votre prénom c'est
e
raphaël
avec un tréma sur le oui alors ce film
c'est une comédie romantique en même
temps il ya de la science fiction en
même temps on ressent des influences un
peu un jour sans fin c'est une vraie
déclaration d'amour aussi au cinéma vous
aviez vous aviez quoi en tête en
réalisant moi mon souhait c'était de
faire un film qui respecte le genre la
comédie romantique dans la comédie
romantique également comédienne aux
romantiques donc en fait il fallait
respecter les deux mots vraiment donner
vraiment de quoi rire est vraiment de
quoi s'émerveiller de l'amour et donc on
a essayé de faire ça et puis en même
temps j'avais en effet plein de
références et les références les assume
j'aime trop le cinéma pour ne pas les
assumer donc du coup oui raphaël
s'appellera fait leurs amis dans le film
parce que harold ramis c'est lui qui a
réalisé un jour sans fin et qu'il ya
plein de clins d'oeil dans le film comme
ça à des films qui m'ont bercé et qui
sont décrites pour plein de gens
maintenant quoi tu perds tu vois que
j'ai me tourner le dos à ce que l'état
bits comme ça tu connais moins coûteux
fait dix piges compte aucune concurrence
semble donc c'est pas ma meilleure amie
mais oui je connais tu habites la part
dont ben moi je connais pas tu habites
d'accord jeu et puis joue pas au ping
pong depuis des piges donc si tu as
envie de retrouver ton coéquipier et
habite faut que tu m'aides à retourner
dans ma vie d'avant phoenix c'est aussi
un film sur sur l'amitié sur les amitiés
de longue date et amitiés qui se créent
au collège c'est aussi un couple dans
leur manière quoi oui c'est vrai la
tonique mais
ils s'aiment ces deux là et le film
décrit vachement bien ça sur le rapport
d'amitié comme quelque chose d'un pilier
de ville quoi on a je pense qu'on a très
très bon ami à peu il ya toujours le
meilleur pote dans ce genre de film ou
la meilleure pote c'est un classique du
genre
mais il n'est pas toujours aussi bien
voilà et en fait non mais ça je sais pas
mais en tout cas c'est le but
mais le le travail c'était de faire en
sorte que ce personnage soit
indispensable à l'histoire principale
donc à une rom com
il ya aussi un buddy movie et en fait on
a fait en sorte que l'équilibré soit
toujours bon pour que pour que l'on soit
jamais lassé de l'une ou de l'autre des
deux histoires me regarde et voilà la
flèche c'est la malta flèche
namur garde sa prochaine soit on fait
tous les deux avec françois vous
connaissiez joséphine et françois je
crois que govou en un week-end c'est ça
pour briser la glace
on a passé du temps ensemble avant le
tournage a travaillé à lire le script
improvisé des petites choses à vivre
ensemble quoi à picoler français on a
rigolé refaire la fête et notamment un
petit j'étais pas là et notamment un
petit week end organisé par hugo à
prague où il a pris une petite caméra
pour filmer quelques images dont
certaines ont fini dans le film et je
crois le premier joué et nous a dit
balla j'ai une idée vous allez prendre
un bain tous les deux ensemble et on l'a
fait sans se connaître c'est pas bien
mais du coup ça brise la glace en voilà
c'était les images ne sont pas dans le
film mais voilà excuses
ces reptiles chose de comédie romantique
il ya plein de certains films où ça a
été utilisé aussi par exemple titanic
il ya donc un gros bang
elle a beau se calmer avant dans la
tasse ils ont fait la sem 2 où il a
dessiné où elle se met tout nu face à
lui et c'est la première scène qu'ils
ont tourné justement pour briser la
glace et après ils se sont dit on m'a
très bien peu tous les lancers on peut
le faire on pour la conter une histoire
d'amour tous les cadres d'être
romantique dans la vraie vie soit ouais
ouais ça j'en suis sûr j'aimerais pas
proposer le rôle si nantes c'est vrai je
le sens prêt
il me sentais romantique gestion terre
romantique non mais c'est vrai je pense
oui sans être trop fort d'ailleurs il a
semblé dire de manière de voir le couple
manière de voir l'amour juste mois de
mai dernier au choix une rose rouge ça
leur nom justement censé dévoiler mais
cette complicité des mais l'humour mais
les madeleines saveur coco
non merci non pas si non c'est facile je
sache et des habous coco dégoût coco non
vraiment ça va merci
juste avant de se quitter un mot chacun
sur
sur votre jeunesse sur vos années
collège puisque le film démarre sur leur
rencontre au collège j'étais tellement
redoublé que finalement chez moi j'étais
en quittant sa seconde 3 secondes et son
travail joséphine je pense qu'elle a su
tout sauter l des classes pendant le
même temps évoqué qu'est-ce qu'on fait
sans rattraper ça aurait été très la
rencontre on aurait même classe voilà la
fema en tout cas donc mon inconnu
vraiment c'est le 3 avril au cinéma et
il ne faut pas passer à côté de ce film
merci à tous les quatre merci
[Musique]